this video is made possible by vincero
watches luxury handcrafted watches at
fair prices
now the biggest sale ever is going on
right now you can check it out through
the link
below
in the first two years of world war ii
the allies were stunned by the speed
coordination and
efficacy of germany's armored divisions
they were seemingly
unstoppable this was the success of
blitzkrieg
tactics or lightning war this success
was attributed to the leadership and the
military genius
of today's protagonist even before the
war his published works had
brought him to the attention of military
leaders worldwide he became known
as the father of blitzkrieg his loyalty
to germany
was undisputed but his support of hitler
and the nazi leadership
it was not so clear-cut he was in fact
one of the very few generals who dared
shouting back at the fuhrer and even
disobeying his orders
join me today as we look at the story
of general heinz gadarian
before we dive bomb like i stuck her
into heinz gadarian's life i will bore
you with some military theory as we do
need to clarify some concepts blitzkrieg
tactics can be defined as the use of
combined forces of tanks motorized
infantry and artillery
breaking the opponent's defenses on a
narrow front bypassing pockets of
resistance and striking deep
into enemy territory ground forces are
provided close support by the air force
tasked with bombing key objectives and
establishing local air superiority the
term blitzkrieg was actually coined by
the british press not by the german high
command as a means to describe the swift
invasion of poland in september of 1939.
german military would have used the term
bowung skrieg i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing that right i'm doing my best
my
pronunciation dictionary didn't know
that one or also in english something i
can pronounce
war of movements and it's a military
doctrine rather than a tactic a tactic
is a method of employing forces
in combat or the how of how you can win
a battle military doctrine is the set of
principles by
which the armed forces are organized
doctrine shapes
strategies which are the plans to
achieve victory in any war
and i really hope i got all of that
right if any of you have served or are
serving in the military please do feel
free to correct me in the comments
be going back to the bowongan's creek
this doctrine had been
shaping the german armed forces plans
since world war one
heinz guderian and other military
theorists after him
perfected the doctrine and took
advantage of current technology to
maximize the potential
of its theoretical principles so rather
than calling gadarian the father of
blitzkrieg he should be
rather the optimizer of bawungung's
creek and that is
definitely less catchy but with that out
of the way let's begin
with the life of heinz
[Music]
heinz gadarian was born on the 7th of
june 1888 in culm
in prussia which is now polish territory
he was born into a close-knit family
with a long-standing military tradition
his father friedrich had been a colonel
in the prussian than the german army
heinz followed his father's career
enthusiastically as a teenager and
enlisted in the principal cadet school
in
berlin he was an ambitious and
determined student his teachers
described him
as being always serious but that wasn't
always the case because sometimes he was
also described
as very serious hein soon gained a
useful leadership skill and that's the
ability
of speaking very concisely and clearly
to communicate his ideas and
later his orders at will he could turn
his communication style into one that
was cold
and hurting this made him equally famous
and feared at the cadet school but
not very popular it appears he made no
friends there at least until he
graduated and got his first command post
in 1907 at the age of 19 heinz was sent
to join the 10th battalion
as second lieutenant under the command
of his father we don't know
if this was by design but we do know
that heinz did not take advantage of the
situation
and slouch around friedrich gadarian was
a stern leader both
loved and feared by his soldiers and his
families and he would not
make any favors for his son heinz worked
hard and learned a great deal from his
father
two years later heinz gaddarian's unit
was transferred to the gossela barracks
in the haas mountains one of the most
scenic parts of germany he had some time
to go horse riding hunting and did some
socializing and that was when he met and
fell in love
with marguerite gurne whom he nicknamed
gretel gretel was the perfect companion
for heinz as
she shared and supported his ambitious
outlook on life they would marry in 1913
and heinz later described her as the
perfect soldier's wife she could be cool
and
sensible when needed most of the time
she was able to calm her husband when he
was seized by
his frequent fits of anger very often in
his later life gadarian's hot temper got
him into trouble for
lashing out at subordinates and
superiors alike on many occasions he had
to be saved from disciplinary measures
by a superior who appreciated his
exceptional military ability despite his
poor impulse control
later in life gadarian took snap
decisions to disobey orders from above
he clearly had a talent for leading he
just couldn't be bothered
with any following
[Music]
the year before his wedding 1912 heinz
wanted to broaden his technical training
and so
he transferred to the third telegraph
battalion here he studied hard to become
a specialist in the new radio signal
equipment already at this stage he saw
communications as a decisive element for
military victory
his studies were not limited to the
radio he studied military strategy in
french and english so that he could
study military theory textbooks in those
languages
his efforts were noticed and heinz was
offered the chance to join
a class of 168 officers to attend a
three-year program at the war academy in
berlin
he was moving fast so much so that he
earned the nickname
schneller heinz or quick heinz although
he did not see himself as particularly
quick
heinz did not like to rush mindlessly
into action often quoting a line by
military leader helmuth von mulker the
line was first reckon
then risk heinz-guderian studies were
interrupted when two
gunshots rang out in sarajevo on the
28th of june
1914 the assassination of archduke franz
ferdinand of the austro-hungarian empire
which led to the outbreak of world war
one in just a matter of weeks
with his radio qualification gadarian
joined the wireless communication staff
in november of 1914 he was promoted to
first lieutenant and only one year later
he was promoted to captain
his work allowed him to witness almost
every front of the war including the
disaster on the man and the slaughter of
vador the carnage he viewed may have
influenced his thoughts on developing
mechanized warfare to protect the
infantryman
and achieve a quick victory he never had
the chance to command a fighting unit
but his radio station
it sometimes came under attack and he
had to fight his way out as a result he
was awarded the iron cross second
and first class in early 1918 he was
tested at an advanced officer training
program where he showed the ability for
solving tactical problems with
unusual actions this impressed his
instructors who accepted his request to
join the general staff of the army high
command
it is evident how the world war one
experience has shaped guderian's
thoughts on blitzkrieg
and how they could improve it his post
in charge of radio communications taught
him the
importance of the wireless especially
when it came to coordinating the
movements of
separate infantry artillery and cavalry
divisions although not directly involved
cadarians studied the tactics employed
by the stos throughpen also known
as the shock troops or stormtroopers
these units were
usually successful in infiltrating weak
spots of enemy trenches to
encircle capture or destroy command
centers but their successes were
short-lived because of the limitations
of well just being human the extent of
the advance of shock troops was limited
by how fast and how far they could walk
before
succumbing to exhaustion in many cases
capturing a well-stocked british or
french position would mean
failure as shock troops would sit down
to eat guderian's theories proposed to
solve these limits by supporting
infantry with mechanized and motorized
units they would require in turn the
integration and coordination of separate
arms
at the lowest unit level in mutually
supportive functions
in lay terms here if you have a platoon
of infantry say 30 to 50 men fighting
alongside a tank platoon say
four or six tanks and they support each
other it is easier for them to cooperate
rather than have a whole division of 15
000 foot soldiers on one side
and a division of tanks on the other
again military friends correct me if i'm
wrong here but i think that's how it is
[Music]
when the war ended in german defeat the
treaty of versailles allowed the country
to maintain only a small army of 100 000
troops with
no tanks or aircraft post wargadarian
served as an instructor teaching
tactics and military history it was
during these years that he expanded
developed and perfected his take on the
idea of the war of movement he would
digest the works on mechanized warfare
of british theorists captain lidl heart
and
major general fuller he began publishing
articles in military journals and won a
reputation for
thinking clearly on controversial
matters in 1927 he was promoted to the
rank of
major his role was at the head of the
command for all motorized transport
units and
he also taught transport tactics at the
berlin military academy basically his
units were
tasked with logistics and transport not
actual combat but this did not prevent
him from
taking advantage and playing around with
his trucks he equipped some of these
vehicles with
wooden turrets armed with guns and he
moved them around a training ground as
fighting units
his superiors were not happy and they
put an end to his experiments but
what he could not learn at home well he
would learn abroad
in 1929 gadarian traveled to sweden
where he visited a tank battalion and
then he went to kazan in russia here he
visited a secret tank testing facility
that was co-developed by the weimar
republic and the soviet government he
also probably met soviet tank commanders
here who would later become his enemies
by 1933 when the nationalist socialist
party rose to power
heinz was colonel gadarian gadarian
continued with
his articles about armoured and
motorized warfare and helped with
solving technical problems of the first
panzer specimens
gadarian continued with his articles
about armoured and motorized warfare and
helped with solving the technical
problems of the first panzer specimens
gadarian's theories would find fertile
ground with the nazis and
their rearmament policies in early 1934
gadarian organized a demonstration of
panzer tactics for hitler he later
recalled
the chancellor was much taken by the
speed and precision
of movement of our units and said
repeatedly that's
what i need hitler was ecstatic and
would provide support to guderian's
innovation
even though the two men often clashed in
spectacular shouting matches nazi
leadership proceeded to
reinstall conscription thus ignoring the
treaty of versailles hitler authorized
another violation of the treaty that was
the creation of three panzer divisions
qadarian was made the commander
of the second panzer division and
shortly thereafter was promoted to major
general then
lieutenant general in charge of the 16th
army corps
in 1938 guderian's units were the
spearhead of the anschluss with
austria and the invasion of the
sudetenland the german-speaking region
of czechoslovakia
these were the years of appeasement so
the guns on his tanks they were still
silent
a few months later guderian was promoted
to commander in chief of all the
fast troops or schnellenthruppen the
perfect job for
chanella heinz if you will he was now in
charge of the recruitment
training tactics and technique for all
motorized and armored units
a great leader and a poor follower now
gadarian would be able to bring the full
weight of his studies
doctrine and personality to the german
panzer divisions
he could finally formalize and implement
his take on the blitzkrieg which
is number one attacks should be led by
large concentrated numbers of tanks
tanks should not be dispersed amongst
other units like it was common practice
in the
british and the french armies at that
time as godarian put it you hit somebody
with your fist and not with your fingers
spread
number two the infantry transported by
trucks and half trucks should closely
follow the tank platoons to support them
this involves maintaining the logistics
train occupying positions taking
prisoners neutralizing anti-tank weapons
number three aircraft and artillery are
intended to support both tanks and
infantry by striking it to enemy armor
and fortifications from
above and from afar number four the
units involved require
reliable means of communication that
involves connecting tanks via radio
transmitters for coordinated joint
action
to generate support for the blitzkrieg
guderian wrote and published his first
book
archong panzer and yes that is how you
pronounce it the
the exclamation points are right there
in the title it's not akron panzer it's
achtung panza
the book became a military best seller
essential reading for any officer
this book cemented gadarian's reputation
as father of the blitzkrieg although
it should be stressed again that these
were not his original ideas he had
simply perfected and formalized concepts
that
were borrowed from german and foreign
military strategists an obscure french
officer a certain child de gaulle
was already a proponent of mechanized
war of movement in the 1920s
inspired by polish officer sikorsky but
in the end what counts is not he
theorizes but who puts things into
practice
in the book gadarian summed up his
thinking as such
deeds are more important than words the
goddess of battle
will crown only the most daring with
laurels
so this video it talks a lot about nazis
and even though
it's not really about nazis it's about
warfare the chances of you actually
seeing ads from youtube on this video
are pretty much
nil if you did see any ads on this video
that is not this one for vincero
it's just a demonstration of quite how
strange the youtube advertising
algorithm is
i don't really know what's going on but
i really think it's unlikely you see
anything
but anyway sponsors like vincero they do
make these videos possible and if you
want to support us
and look great at the same time you
should get hooked up with a vincero
watch recently i got this one
it's called a rogue i'll just take it
off to show you guys they sent me this
last month i went for black on black i
know this will be blurry i'll just do
some b-roll
and you also have different strap
options as well so you can choose what
strap you want to have with it
previously i had this one with a brown
strap which i think is cool this one's
called a chronos i think
cronus you got that marble thing in the
back blue back silver outside brown
strap
magic of television watch this and then
also i got it with a black strap so you
got that black strap there
so see you've got lots of different
options i like the rogue the rogue's
perfect for summer
because it's got this like rubber strap
so you're not going to be sweating into
the leather but you can swap that out
if you want to right now vincero are
actually having their biggest sale ever
with
huge discounts on their entire range
both watches that you saw today
are included as is everything else the
sale only goes on to the 18th of august
and some watches will sell out so better
to have a look sooner rather than later
and please do go through the link in the
description below
that helps support this show or just go
direct to vincero watches dot com
forward slash biographics
in september of 1939 chanel heinz was
able to put his words
into action during the aggression of
poland gadarian was assigned to the 19th
corps consisting of one panzer division
and two motorized infantry divisions
which he led in an impressive drive
against polish defenses
but the real revolutionary actions took
place during the battle of france in the
following year when the veermark
concentrated their armored division and
the luftwaffe
at the schwerpent or main point of
effort achieving a decisive breakthrough
against the allies
the original plan for the invasion of
france was a repeat of the schlieffen
plan used
back in world war one a quick attack
through belgium and into northern france
but hitler he was not convinced you
won't get away with an operation
like that twice running hitler demanded
a new approach based on secrecy and
surprise
the result was operation sickle cut
devised by general von manstein
and guderian the idea was to lure french
and british forces into belgium and
holland by
launching decoy attacks there while the
main thrust would be advancing through
the ardennes forest considered
too thickly wooded for tank operations
the success of this planet depended on
concentration
and coordination the french had more and
better tanks than the germans but
their use was ruled by an outdated
doctrine they were thinly dispersed
along the front
and they had few radios von manstein
instead had amassed
seven armored divisions at the spearhead
of the aten offensive
guderian was in charge of three
divisions and he was ordered across the
river muse at sedon where the prussians
had defeated napoleon iii in 1870.
the day of the offensive arrived the
10th of may 1940.
so did everything go as planned well not
really the german divisions
in the lowlands did manage to lure and
pin down the allies but the swift drive
through the ardennes soon turned into a
massive traffic jam
allied aircraft could have easily
destroyed the german column but the
luftwaffe did its job and
protected them from the air the traffic
cleared and guderian reached the muse
one day
earlier than planned on the 13th of may
he had infantry and engineers cross the
river in inflatable rafts so they could
neutralize
french bunkers and build pontoon bridges
for the tanks
by nightfall the defenders were routed
the french counter-attacked the next
morning but gaddarian leading from the
front had
made the snap decision to set up a
defensive line with artillery high
command ordered him to wait for
reinforcements but guderian disobeyed
and pushed ahead
between may the 15th and the 17th
guderian repulsed armored french attacks
in
the stone and monk on a this was not
easy though amongst his opponents was
brigadier general charles de gaulle who
almost managed to capture cadarian as he
remembered his tanks succeeded in
penetrating to within a mile of my
advanced headquarters
this was guderian's masterpiece
operation sickle cut
was a success beyond any expectations
this appeared too good to be true to
high command which may explain
their later cautiousness by the 24th of
may the bulk of the british
expeditionary force was
encircled at dunkirk easy prey but
general
von runstead guderian's immediate
superior feared an allied pincer
movement and
ordered that his panzers be stopped 10
miles from dunkirk
godarian was allowed to proceed only on
the 26th but by then the french had
strengthened their defenses around the
dunkirk pocket
allowing for the evacuation of the
british this surely frustrated godarian
but
overall his campaign was a success
resulting in the french surrender
in june
emboldened by the victories brought on
by the war of movement
hitler started drawing plans to invade
the soviet union
operation barbarossa was launched in
june of 1941
and chanella heinz was again to the fall
the campaign
was nightmarish as we now know the army
units were followed by the ss
einsatzgruppen especially dedicated to
rounding up deporting and
murdering millions of jews roma and
other targeted groups in soviet
territory
gadarian was leading panzer gripper
number two headed towards moscow in late
1941.
was he involved in these atrocities or
was even aware
evidence suggests that godarian was not
an anti-semite it is possible he knew
that the jews and other so-called
undesirables were being sent to
concentration camps for
a life of hardship and for sure he knew
that his pandas had been built by slave
laborers from
occupied nations but it might be that he
didn't know about the systematic
killings
even his wife gretel a stronger admirer
of hitler's than gadarians later
was shocked when she learned of the
truth behind the camps both were
convinced that himmler and the ss were
the only ones responsible
and not hitler if he somehow had no
knowledge of the death squads guderian
surely had realized by this time that
hitler was not a leader
that he could follow blindly as the
fuhrer imposed ill-judged decisions on
his generals gadarian was frustrated by
the lack of criticism
as the russian campaign hardened he
wrote to his wife everybody is scared of
the fuhrer and nobody dares say anything
as ottoman winter set in godarians
panzers stalled in the mud
and the snow and were harassed by
increasingly stiff russian resistance
one of his most famous quotes is there
are no desperate situations
there are only desperate people and yet
this situation would prove
desperate even to him we have severely
underestimated the russians the extent
of the country and the treachery
of the climate this is the revenge of
reality
in december of 1941 godarian defied an
order from hitler to
advance on moscow and instead pulled
back his panzer grouper
100 miles from the capital this
insubordination it cost him his job
hitler forced guderian to retire but
rewarded him with a farm in prussia
countryside life though it did not sit
well with guderian apparently during
this period a pre-existing heart
condition it worsened but he had no time
to
properly recuperate he was soon going to
be recalled back into service
[Music]
in 1943 the situation for the axis
powers was worsening and the military
convinced hitler that godarian was
needed hitler agreed and he recalled
gadarian from retirement appointing him
inspector general of the panzer forces
this did not appease his tamper though
and his shouting matches with the fuhrer
they resumed
in summer of 1943 he argued to contain
soviet counter-attacks by
a strategy of dynamic mobile defense
this would imply
engaging the red army in a series of
local clashes to defeat them in detail
and
delay their advance the strategy was a
contradiction of his beloved blitzkrieg
but
it just shows how he had realized that
this was not a silver bullet that was
suitable to all
theaters of war hitler did not listen to
his advice though preferring the
proposal of general zeitzler and that
was to concentrate all german armor
divisions in kursk to
defeat the soviets in one decisive
battle the battle of kursk raged on
from the 4th to the 12th of july 1943.
it was a close call with heavy losses on
both sides but
in the end the soviets prevailed and
from then on the war on the eastern
front it became
one of retreat for the germans the
following year after yet another
suspension for insubordination guderian
was
approached by the circle of colonel von
staufenberg who
were plotting to assassinate hitler
gadarian refused to participate although
he did not report the conspirators
nor worn the fuhrer the failed
assassination it took place on the 20th
of july 1944
followed by a purge of military
leadership ironically now gadarian was
one of the few remaining leaders that
hitler could trust for the war effort
the fuhrer appointed guderian as the new
army chief of staff
gadarian's main focus now was to defend
germany from the impending soviet
counter-attack
and occupation he knew very well that
the war could not be won but intended to
resist as long as possible the main
hindrance to his plans
was the meddling of the fuhrer himself
[Music]
in march of 1945 he was vocally opposing
hitler in staff meetings
hitler decided to get rid of gadarian
and ordered him to take six weeks of
sick leave the order was meant to
hurt him but ironically it might have
saved him berlin would be surrounded by
the red army the following month while
heinz and gretel were in a cardiology
hospital in munich
this is where u.s forces captured
gadarian on the 10th of may 1945.
it was the fifth anniversary of
operation sickle cut
gadarian was sent to nuremberg but was
not immediately put on trial the
russians wanted to charge him with war
crimes but the western allies didn't
comply
in 1946 godarian was imprisoned in the
pow camps of allendorf and
neustadt during his captivity allied
military tried to evaluate the extent of
his involvement in the nazi war crimes
as he did not cooperate with
interrogations they placed him in
confinement with two other generals
gear and lieb and wiretapped the cell
even then
he kept his cards close to his chest
this is the only conversation in which
he admits support
of party policies yeah any objective
observer will admit that national
socialism raised the social status of
the worker
and in some respects even his standard
of living as long as that was possible
lieb this is one of the great
achievements of national socialism
the excesses of national socialism were
in the first and final analysis due to
the warped personality of the fuhrer
gadarian the fundamental principles were
fine
it was not enough to charge him and
gadarium was released on his 60th
birthday
the 7th of june 1948. in the following
years he contributed to the organization
of the bundeswehr the
armed forces of west germany he returned
to writing drafting his memoirs and
pending more military theory works his
autobiography panzolida also known as
memoirs of a soldier was published in
1952 becoming an international best
seller soon after its publication
gadarian's health failed
he died in schwangel by fusing on the
14th of may 1954
the anniversary of his victory on the
moose
so far i've told you the most widely
accepted version of godarian's life
story the official version that's been
held up for many decades after his death
however in the 2000s gadarian's career
and legacy have come under scrutiny from
several historians such as russell hart
marcel stein or pierre paulo batastelli
these authors claim that godarian's
military capabilities were undeniable
although he greatly exaggerated them
through his writings
hart for example claims his victories
always came from a position of strength
and numerical superiority
never from a position of weakness
batastelli argues that his true genius
was as an author and as a publicist of
his own image as the
mastermind behind the blitzkrieg it can
be argued that being in a position of
strength is a sign of skill too as it
requires planning and preparation and
that autobiographies naturally tend to
be
embellished accounts other arguments are
a little more disturbing though guderian
always portrayed himself as
distanced from nazi excesses and as a
fair combatant
yet marcel stein writes that godarian's
units in russia actively executed people
under his orders the
infamous commissar orders this was the
summary execution of war prisoners
suspected to be political commissars or
actively representing bolshevik ideology
and that
that would be a war crime that would not
be forgiven at the nuremberg trials
hart also claimed that during the 1944
coup against hitler gadarian
optimistically played
both sides ready to join the winner to
get a promotion
as chief of staff as acting chief of
staff on the 29th of july gadarian
issued
an order forcing all officers to become
members of the nazi party
implying that he was closer to nazi
ideology than
if you did please available hit that
thumbs up button but even better than
that
why not check out vincero for a great
watch and it also helps support this
show so please consider doing that
and as always thank you for watching
you